their sexual value go out once people  see you've got only fans there's always  going to be people in public they'll say  no I'd never be with someone from any  fans but check their DMS no most would  be there forever yeah  okay I'll give you an example look look  at Lana Rhodes she can't even keep a man  that's one person from from that I know  but that's like what one of the most I  would argue one of the most I would  argue one of the most beautiful women I  mean I don't know I don't I'm not a  consumer of that content  but is that part I feel like it changes  across the demographic obviously that's  someone that we've looked at from a  different one but there's people like  you I'm not sure if any of you have  heard of Ruby Rose someone else yeah but  there's people and people look at her  and still be like that's still enough